he also has been gripping the hands of
those close to him in the hospital
signed for them that he acknowledges
them recognizes that they are there and
are meaningful to him put that all
together and it's really hard to imagine
Andrew coming out with with better news
than than this Buffalo Bills safety
Demar Hamlin is reportedly awake and
holding hands with his family in the
hospital after suffering Cardiac Arrest
during Monday night's game against the
Cincinnati Bengals he opened his eyes
last night which had to be just really
an incredible moment of considering that
all that he has been through during an
appearance on NFL now Thursday League
Insider Ian Rappaport reported that
Demar opened his eyes on Wednesday night
hearing and seeing him open his eyes
amazing he has been responsive which is
also extremely positive neurologically
intact is how the bills refer to him
demar's agent Rob Butler confirmed all
that to CNN on Thursday and agency one
sports who reps the athlete tweeted an
update on the 24 year old's Health
writing that the outpouring of support
has been amazing and adding that Demar
has made substantial Improvement
overnight before asking fans to continue
to pray for his recovery
meanwhile the bills also shared an
update on demar's health Thursday
tweeting that he has shown remarkable
Improvement and while he is still
critically ill he is making steady
progress when someone has a Sudden
Impact or blunt trauma to the chest if
it happens at a specific part of the
cardiac cycle then that can lead to a
ventricular arrhythmia or an unstable
heart arrhythmia which can ultimately
lead to sudden Cardiac Arrest the
incident occurred during the first
quarter of the game after Damar made a
tackle stood up and immediately
collapsed on the field Demar was down
for at least 15 minutes paramedics
administered CPR he was taken off the
field in an ambulance and the game was
postponed
I mean it was tough like you're just
seeing everyone's reactions it was it
was a little scary I mean because you
know the hit didn't look bad but then
you saw everyone's reactions you're like
what are we missing like what's going on
the NFL later released a statement
confirming that Demar suffered cardiac
arrest and was in critical condition
both of demar's parents were at the game
when he collapsed and are by his side as
he receives treatment his parents like
they're Fighters I mean they are like
it's one of the best support systems
that anyone can have and honestly it
shows why Demar is so strong-willed and
caring they obviously are nervous it's
it's a little scary for them
um but they're optimistic because they
know Demar on Tuesday E.T spoke to
Jordan Rooney a spokesperson and friend
of Demars who said the family is
grateful for all the love and support we
can't come together even Bengals and
Bills fans can come together and you
know the families they're honestly just
incredibly thankful they just keep
saying like they're just in disbelief
and it's like wow this is amazing I
can't believe how good these people are
to us
[Music]